NOT THE ONLY ONE WHO HAS BEEN
LOCKED DOWN IN THIS COUNTRY.
EVEN NOW, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
REMAIN SUBJECTED TO
UNPRECEDENTED RESTRICTIONS ON
THEIR PERSONAL LIVES, DAILY
LIVES, FAMILY LIVES.
THE LOCKDOWNS CONTINUE IN MANY
PLACES, IF YOU’RE LIVING ON IT
YOU DEFINITELY KNOW.
AS A RESULT OF THIS, TENS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE NOW
UNEMPLOYED, A HUGE NUMBER OF
THEM HAVE NO PROSPECTS OF
WORKING AGAIN, MANY THOUSANDS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE CLOSED AND
WILL NEVER REOPEN.
AMERICANS HAVE SEEN THEIR
MARRIAGE IS DISSOLVED, BECAME
CLINICALLY DEPRESSED.
SOME HAVE BLAMED THEIR WEDDING,
OTHERS WERE BANNED FROM THE
GOVERNMENT BY FROM BURYING THEIR
LOVED ONES AND FUNERALS.
AN UNKNOWN NUMBER HAVE TAKEN
THEIR OWN LIVES IN DESPAIR.
OTHERS HAVE GONE TO THE STREETS
TO RIOT BECAUSE BOTTLED UP RAGE
AND FRUSTRATION TAKE MANY FORMS.
THE COST OF SHUTTING DOWN THE
UNITED STATES IN DENYING OUR
CITIZENS DESPERATELY NEEDED
CONTACT WITH ONE ANOTHER IS HARD
TO CALCULATE BUT THE COST HAS
BEEN STAGGERING.
THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING
ALL THIS, WE FACED A GLOBAL
CALAMITY, THE WORST PANDEMIC
SINCE THE SPANISH FLU, THAT FLU
KILLED 50 MILLION PEOPLE.
WE HAD NO CHOICE.
WE DID THE RIGHT THING.
THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE TELLING US.
IS IT TRUE, THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION MATTERS NOT JUST
BECAUSE THE TRUTH ALWAYS MATTERS
BUT BECAUSE THE CREDIBILITY OF
OUR LEADERS IS AT STAKE HERE,
THIS IS THE BIGGEST DECISION
THEY MADE IN OUR LIFETIMES, THEY
WERE ABLE TO MAKE IT, THEY
RULED, BECAUSE WE LET THEM.
THEIR POWER COMES FROM US.
SO THE QUESTION NOW AND ALWAYS
IS, ARE THEY WORTHY OF THAT
POWER?
IT’S NOT A CONVERSATION THEY
WANT TO HAVE AN RIGHT NOW THEY
DON’T HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
ALL OF US ARE DISTRACTED AND
MESMERIZED BY THE WOKE
REVOLUTION UNDERWAY OUTSIDE.
THEY CREATED A SEPARATE COUNTRY
IN SEATTLE.
AS WE SAID, WE WILL BRING YOU
THE LATEST ON THAT IN JUST A
MINUTE BUT WE THINK IT’S WORTH
TAKING A PAUSE TO ASSESS WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WERE IN FACT LYING
TO US ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS AND
OUR RESPONSE TO IT.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS THIS, YES,
THEY WERE DEFINITELY LYING.
AS A MATTER OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
CONCLUSIVELY, THE LOCKDOWNS WERE
NOT NECESSARY.
WE CAN PROVE THAT AND HERE’S THE
MOST POWERFUL EVIDENCE, STATES
THAT NEVER LOCKED DOWN AT ALL,
STATES WHERE PEOPLE WERE ALLOWED
TO LIVE LIKE AMERICANS AND NOT
COWER IN INDOORS ALONE, TURNED
OUT NO WORSE THAN THEY COULD
STATES THAT HAD MANDATORY
QUARANTINE, THE STATES YOU
PROBABLY LIVE IN.
THE STATES THAT DID LOCK DOWN
AND WERE QUICK TO REOPEN HAVE
NOT SEEN EXPLOSIONS OF
CORONAVIRUS CASES PAID ALL OF
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THEY SAID WOULD HAPPEN WITH
GREAT CONFIDENCE.
THE MEDIA PREDICTED MASS DEATH
IN PLACES OF LAKE OF THE OZARK,
NEW YORK CITY, MARYLAND, BUT
THOSE DEATHS NEVER HAPPENED.
IN THE END, THE CORONAVIRUS
TURNED OUT TO BE A DANGEROUS
DISEASE BUT A MANAGEABLE DISEASE
LIKE SO MANY OTHERS.
FAR MORE DANGEROUS WHERE THE
LOCKDOWNS THEMSELVES.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN NEW YORK,
PENNSYLVANIA, NEW JERSEY,
PANICKED AND INCOMPETENT
GOVERNORS FORCED NURSING HOMES
TO ACCEPT CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS.
THE MEDIA WOULD RATHER TELL YOU
WHY YOU NEED TO HATE YOUR
NEIGHBOR FOR THE COLOR OF HIS
SKIN.
THE MEDIA DEFINITELY DON’T WANT
TO REVISIT WHAT THEY WERE SAYING
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO AND THEY
WERE ACTING AS PRESS AGENTS FOR
POWER DRUNK DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS.
NEWS ANCHORS WERE ORDERING YOU
TO STOP ASKING QUESTIONS AND
OBEY.
>> WHILE MOST AMERICANS ARE
STAYING INSIDE, IF THEY ARE NOT
PROTESTING -- THEY ARE NOT HAPPY
ABOUT BEING TOLD TO STAY HOME.
STAYING HOME SAVES LIVES.
>> THE REST OF US SHOULD BE
STAYING AT HOME FOR THE PEOPLE
WE LOVE AND TO KEEP US FARTHER
APART WILL ULTIMATELY BRING US
CLOSER TOGETHER.
OUR COLLECTIVE CONSCIENTIOUS
ACTIONS STAYING HOME.
>> Tucker: IF YOU LOVE YOUR
MOTHER YOU WILL DO WHAT I SAY.
TURNS OUT CABLE NEWS ANCHORS
DON’T MAKE VERY SUBTLE
PROPAGANDA.
AND THEN MEMORIAL DAY ARRIVED
AND SOME STATES STARTED TO
REOPEN, MILLIONS OF GRATEFUL
AMERICANS HEADED OUTDOORS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MONTHS.
AND THE MEDIA ATTACKED THEM FOR
DOING THAT, CALLED THEM KILLERS.
SWIMMING WITH YOUR KIDS, THEY
TOLD US, WAS TANTAMOUNT TO MASS
MURDER.
>> JAM-PACKED POOL PARTIES AT
THE LAKE OF THE OZARKS RESORT
AND OTHER PLACES, FEW IF ANY
PEOPLE WERE WEARING MASKS OR
PRACTICING SOCIAL DISTANCING.
>> OVERCROWDED POOLS DESPITE THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC.
BUNCHED UP IN WHAT LOOKS LIKE A
KIND OF HUMANS DO.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THOSE
CROWDS THOUGHT THEY WERE FOR
WHAT THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES IN
AND THAT IS NOT TO CARE ABOUT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY PART OF THIS.
>> LOOK AT THIS, IT’S KIND OF
CRAZY CONSIDERING WE WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC,
THAT IS CURVING THE CURVE,
THAT’S NOT FLATTENING IT.
>> MASSIVE CROWD OF PEOPLE
CRAMMED TOGETHER AS IF IT WERE
AN ORDINARY HOLIDAY WEEKEND
DESPITE THE RISK OF A VIRUS THAT
HAS KILLED MORE THAN 98,000
PEOPLE.
>> THAT MONTAGE WAS THE OPPOSITE
OF A MENSA MEETING.
THE LAST CLIP YOU SAW WAS FROM
MAY 25TH, OVER TWO WEEKS AGO,
98,000 PEOPLE ARE DEAD, HOW DARE
YOU LEAVE YOUR HOUSE?
YOU DON’T WORK IN THE MEDIA,
YOU’RE NOT ESSENTIAL.
BUT IT DIDN’T TAKE LONG FOR THAT
MESSAGE TO CHANGE COMPLETELY.
IT TOOK PRECISELY FIVE DAYS.
HERE’S THE SAME BRAIN-DEAD
NEWS ANCHOR YOU JUST SAW A LESS
THAN A WEEK LATER, HE’S NO
LONGER ANGRY ABOUT AMERICANS
GOING OUTSIDE AS LONG AS THEY
ARE RIOTING AND BURNING AND NOT
DOING SOMETHING SINFUL LIKE
SWIMMING WITH THEIR CHILDREN,
HE’S DELIGHTED BY IT.
>> IF ANYONE IS JUDGING THIS,
I’M NOT JUDGING THIS, I’M JUST
WONDERING WHAT IS GOING ON
BECAUSE WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
FIGURE OUT THIS EXPERIMENT A
LONG TIME, OUR COUNTRY WAS
STARTED BECAUSE -- THIS IS, THE
BOSTON TEA PARTY, RIOTING, SO DO
NOT GET IT TWISTED AND THINK
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT EVER HAPPENED BEFORE AND
THIS IS SO TERRIBLE AND WHERE
ARE WE AND ALL OF THAT, THIS IS
HOW THIS COUNTRY WAS STARTED.
>> Tucker: YEAH, DON’T JUDGE,
THIS IS HOW THIS COUNTRY WAS
STARTED.
BY ELUDING CVS AND SETTING FIRE
TO WENDY’S.
YOU TOOK AMERICAN HISTORY, YOU
KNEW THAT.
ANDREW CUOMO’S BROTHER MUST HAVE
BEEN IN THE SAME HISTORY CLASS
BECAUSE HE HAD THE SAME
REACTION.
>> AMERICA’S MAJOR CITIES ARE
FILLED WITH PEOPLE DEMANDING
THIS COUNTRY BECOME MORE FAIR,
MORE JUST STAND PLEASE SHOW ME
WHERE IT SAYS THAT PROTESTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE POLITE AND
PEACEFUL BECAUSE I CAN SHOW YOU
THAT OUTRAGED CITIZENS ARE THE
ONES WHO HAVE MADE AMERICA WHAT
SHE HAS AND LED TO MANY MAJOR
MILESTONES.
THEY ARE HERE TO YELL,
CRITICIZE, BLAME, AND SHAME.
CITIZENS HAVE NO DUTY TO CHECK
THEIR OUTRAGE.
>> Tucker: SO LAU, ONE MINUTE
THEY WERE MASS MURDERERS ARE
GOING OUTSIDE, NOW THEY ARE
SAM ADAMS, THEY ARE PATRIOTS,
AMERICAN HEROES.
IF ALL OF THIS SEEMS LIKE A
PRETTY ABRUPT PIT IT, RIOTING IS
NOT A HEALTH RISK, AS LONG AS IT
HELPS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S
PROSPECTS IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION, RIOTING WILL NOT
SPREAD THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE CAN BE CERTAIN OF THAT
BECAUSE LAST WEEK HUNDREDS OF
SELF-DESCRIBED PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS SIGNED A LETTER SAYING
SOMETHING.
THEY ANNOUNCED THAT THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER RIOTS ARE A VITAL
CONTRIBUTION TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN YOU GET TO GO
OUTSIDE, YOU DON’T.
THANKS TO CORONAVIRUS YOU DO NOT
HAVE THE RIGHT TO RESUME YOUR
LIFE AND IF YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT
THAT IT’S "WHITE NATIONALISM,"
THAT WAS A PROFESSIONAL
CONCLUSION.
DOES A SINGLE AMERICAN BELIEVE
ANY OF THAT?
NO.
OF COURSE NOT.
IT IS TOO STUPID EVEN FOR CNN TO
REPEAT SO THEY MOSTLY IGNORED
IT.
THAT’S AN OMINOUS SIDE IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DONE TRYING TO
CONVINCE YOU, EVEN TO FOOL YOU,
THEY’RE NOT MAKING ARGUMENTS,
THEY ARE ISSUING DECREES, THEY
THINK THEY CAN.
THEY NO LONGER BELIEVE THEY NEED
YOUR CONSENT TO MAKE BIG
DECISIONS TO RUN THE COUNTRY.
ONCE THE AUTHORITY STOP TRYING
TO CHANGE YOUR MIND, EVEN BY
DECEIT IT MEANS THEY DECIDED TO
USE FORCE, AND THEY HAVE.
DURING THE LOCKDOWNS, PEOPLE WHO
LOVED ONES DIED WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO HAVE FUNERALS FOR THEM.
THINK ABOUT THAT, IT’S HARD TO
THINK OF ANYTHING CRUELER BUT IT
HAPPENED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE,
THEY CLAIMED IT WAS NECESSARY.
IT WAS NOT NECESSARY AND WE KNOW
THAT THEY BECAUSE NOW THAT A MAN
HAS DIED WHOSE DEATH IS
POLITICALLY USEFUL TO
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
AUTHORITIES HAVE GIVEN HIM THREE
FUNERALS AND NOT A WORD ABOUT A
HEALTH RISK.
OR CONSIDER KING COUNTY,
WASHINGTON.
RESTAURANTS IN KING  COUNTY ARE
OPERATING AT 25% CAPACITY,
THAT’S THE LAW NOW.
NONESSENTIAL BUSINESSES ARE
ALLOWED 15% CAPACITY.
THE EFFECT OF THAT IS ECONOMIC
DISASTER, MOST SMALL BUSINESSES
RUN ON VERY SMALL MARGINS, THEY
CAN’T SURVIVE FOR LONG AND MANY
HAVE FAILED.
WHAT SHOULD THEY DO?
THEY SHOULD JOIN ANTIFA,
OBVIOUSLY, BECAUSE IN
KING COUNTY, WASHINGTON, ANTIFA
CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO.
THEY’VE TAKEN AN ENTIRE SIX
BLOCK SECTION OF DOWNTOWN
SEATTLE AND THAT’S FINE, NO
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIRED, THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL.
IS THIS ADDING UP TO OUR
MESSAGE?
YEAH, THE MESSAGES YOU WERE
PLAYED, WE WERE ALL PLAYED,
CORRUPT POLITICIANS SCARED US
INTO GIVING UP CONTROL OVER THE
MOST BASIC QUESTIONS IN OUR OWN
LIVES.
IN THE SAME TIME THEY GAVE MORE
POWER TO THEIR OBEDIENT
FOLLOWERS WHILE KEEPING THE REST
OF US TRAPPED AT HOME AND
CENSORED ONLINE.
THEY USED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY TO SUBVERT DEMOCRACY
AND INSTILL THEMSELVES AS
MONARCHS.
HOW ARE THEY ABLE TO DO THIS?
THE SAD TRUTH IS THEY DID IT
BECAUSE WE LET THEM DO IT.
WE BELIEVED THEM, THEIR
THEREFORE WE OBEYED THEM AND IF